Who is
the god like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of
Mercy The God Who reaches down to
unworthy people.
in the year that King Uzziah died
I saw the Lord.
sitting upon a throne
high and lifted up
and the train of his robe filled the temple.
Above him stood the seraphim.
each had six wings
with two he covered his face with two he covered
his feet with Chewy flu.
And one called to another and said
holy.
Holy.
Holy is the Lord of hosts.
The whole earth is full of his glory.
And the foundations of the thresholds shook.
At the voice of him who called.
The house was filled with smoke.
and I said
Whoa is me.
For I am lost.
For I'm a man of unclean lips.
And I dwell in the midst of a people of unclean lips.
For my eyes have seen the king.
the Lord of hosts
Can you imagine that scene?
Put yourself in Isaiah's shoes as he recorded these words in
chapter 6 of his prophecy.
Do you see the Lord Yahweh hi
and lift it up.
Can you hear the choirs of angels shouting holy?
about this one on the Mountaintop
But then in light of that do you feel what I
say a felt in verse 5?
That because of God's holiness.
You have no right to stand in his
presence.
That you can never reach him.
That there is a huge Chasm of Valley
between you and him.
See that is the fundamental question that we are going to ask.
over the next couple months
with that image of a mountain fixed squarely in our minds.
the question
Who can ascend?
Who can ever Ascend to the mountain of a holy
God to be with him forever?
And if we could ever get there with him.
What does God then require?
of us
That's what we'll see in the Book of Micah.
in the Old Testament
And so if you're not already there take your copy of
God's word and turn with me to the Book of Micah.
Let me first acknowledge that we have some new
friends with us in here kindergartners. I love
the fact that you're in here with us now and we're excited to have
you follow along with us read along here Listen and
talk. We're excited for you and thankful for you.
But right now we're going to the book of Mike and I know all of
you have your Old Testament books memorized in order. So, you know exactly
where Micah is you spent your time in the profits this
week and you're quiet Tom. I know no just kidding like you need to use a
table of content. That's fine. I have to as well, but
let me give you an easy way to find it.
Just open right to the middle. I mean, it's almost exactly in the middle of my
Bible and you can roughly find where it is
there and you'll you'll find that you find these these
profits in order and so you get Isaiah and Jeremiah Ezekiel
Daniel those are there but then you get to the little
ones called the minor not because they're unimportant because they're short you
get Hosea Joel Amos Obadiah Jonah
Micah. So that's where you'll find it there put
a bookmark there because we're gonna be in there for a couple months. You
don't have to worry about finding it next time.
But we'll be there pretty much till Thanksgiving.
But we're going to walk straight through this book called Micah.
And we're going to see how to study a book.
That honestly most of us are pretty unfamiliar with.
Frankly, I'm kind of intimidated by it. It's just it's gonna
be hard to walk through and you'll see why but that's why
I believe God led us to this this little book here.
Because just as much as any of the other 65 books
in the Bible, this one is God's word as well.
So we need to learn how to read it how to understand
it how to apply it. That's one reason, but
also there's another reason.
Because I believe it has a lot to say to a culture like ours.
See Micah was speaking to an historically
God-fearing Nation.
That had gotten pretty comfortable.
And then things started to go south as they drifted away from
God.
And rather than identifying the wrong reasons
for why that was happening in their lives. God got
to the heart of the issue through his
prophet Micah.
He shows them exactly what their problem
is what they're doing what they have on the other side of
this if they keep doing it and it's going to challenge us in many
of the same ways.
So we're going to do today is we're gonna get started by looking at the
context of the book context of
Micah basically just verse one of chapter one.
Really what we know about Micah what we know about his environment what was happening
at the time. We're gonna just see the context.
And then we're going to give a quick overview of the book as well.
Now. We are going to do a pretty deep dive
into the context here.
And so I know that some of you here that and your eyes
glaze over just don't work. There's there's no quiz on the way home. Like I'm not
gonna call you tonight. Ask you what this king's name was just breathe a
little bit. Okay, because I want you to I want
you just to kind of sit and enjoy getting pulled into the story.
That this was 2700 years or so
ago to get pulled into this and see what was happening
is so you have this framework in your head as we go through the rest of
the book to know why he's saying what he's saying because that's why
this is so critically important.
Like if you struggle with the history stuff, we're gonna get into the meat of
it next week. So please come back and you'll be able to walk through and to be more typical
of what we do. But but this is important for
us to understand because what it's going
to help us do is compare.
What is similar about what is happening in Micah's day?
To what's happening today, but also to show what's different
between what they're experiencing and
how that should be applied in versus today what
we experience.
So this is really important is it's hard as it
might be. I'm trying to make it engaging but but this is really important for us
to know as we go into the Book of Micah.
So look at verse 1 of chapter 1 Micah.
The word of the Lord that came to Micah
of morrisheth in the days of jotham ahaz
and has Hezekiah Kings of
Judah.
Which he saw concerning Samaria and Jerusalem.
Now we need to notice a couple really important elements here.
First was he say initially. It was the word of the Lord
that came to Micah.
In other words, this is God's message to people.
This wasn't Micah coming up with something on his
own because he wanted to come down hard on a group of people that he didn't
like.
So he starts judging them. No, that was not it. No, this
was because God said everything that he writes down
here.
Same idea. We see in second Peter 1:21 that
the prophets spoke as God spoke through
them.
proving that they are prophets
Okay, so who was Micah?
We don't have a lot of background information on Micah. We
know his hometown here was more a chef, which is a small town Southwest
of Jerusalem.
But we don't know much about him as a person.
But really honestly, that's not that important compared to
his willingness to be a Divine mouthpiece.
To be the one that God uses to speak these words.
to the people
But we do know a couple things about them. We know he was a prophet because
not only is he saying this here, but he
also shows up elsewhere as a prophet like in Jeremiah 26
verse 18. He's talking to King Hezekiah who
showed up here in verse 1. There's a another way that he's shown
to be prophetic in his actions.
We know he was a prophet. We also know that he was courageous.
in this proclamation of judgment
By the way to a nation that might have been pretty shocked
by his words.
see what we're going to come to find out over the next couple weeks is
that
This entire structure of the economic political
and religious system in his nation
was corrupt.
It had gotten there over time. We'll talk through that a little bit.
But widows and immigrants and the poor were especially vulnerable in
this time frame and yet Micah knowing
that was the culture. He didn't nuanced his
words at all.
In fact, he called it out directly.
Even to a people who thought that
there was no way that God would judge them.
I mean these people were standing to say hey, we got the temple.
Like the presence of God is right here in our city.
There's no way God would judge us.
Like we're good. I mean we got the temple, right?
And Michael looks at him and says yeah, that's true.
But not if you turn away from God.
Not if you are full of Injustice in
your midst in your allowing it to go that that doesn't mean you
have God's presence.
Meaning a lack of repentance brings judgment
no matter who you are.
And so Micah was passionate about God's people reflecting
God's character. His priority is what he was about and he
saw it happen around him that it wasn't and so God used
him to call it out.
So that's a little bit about Micah. But what about these other three names? He mentions
here these Kings of Judah.
Along with he says Samaria and Jerusalem, which
are the locations to which he directed his prophecies.
Well, here's what we have to have a little bit of a history lesson. So if you
remember this as we walked back in time because all the
way back in the book of Exodus where it was God calling out
the 12 tribes of Israel of Jacob his
sons
out of slavery in Egypt
He freed them. It was incredible process miraculous, but
then they wandered about in the desert for about
40 years before entering into the
land that God had promised Abraham called Canaan,
which is what we know now. Today is Israel.
And so they wandered and in that process of as they're
about to come into the promised land Moses stands up in Deuteronomy,
27 and 28 and he warns them. He says
Hey guys. Listen, you're about to go in but there's going to be Temptations in
there that we're going to drift your heart away
from following this Covenant. God has done
with you.
That he's initiated his Covenant and he said here's what you need
to do. And I'm going to bless you. If you do it. I'm going to curse you.
If you don't he says guys there's gonna be stuff there that tempts you.
Be ready be ready and they say oh
we're good. We're in.
Well what we learned throughout Israel's story is that
there were cycles of sin and repentance sin and
repentance sin and repentance the Book of Judges remember
that a couple years ago, like just there was this cycle of
back and forth.
Until eventually what we learn about 1,000 BC thousand
years before Christ came.
Through a series of events. God raised
up David.
As his King for Jacob for Israel the
Twelve Tribes.
And then David's son Solomon was a king that followed him. And really
that was the high point of Israel's history.
Economically socially even religiously
because under Solomon the
temple was built. It was a tabernacle. It was a tent all around
the desert for so long and then God says no
in Jerusalem. I'm putting my my home my Dwelling
Place.
And they build the temple and it is the high point of Israel's history.
But you know if there's a high point then it there's lower
points from there, right?
And so because of Solomon's Rebellion against God and
his sin.
What we learn is that the once unified Kingdom.
High Point 12 tribes celebrating God
we're in the land all of that from that point forward there
was now a divided Kingdom.
And that once unified King splits into two the
North and the South going to put a picture up there. It's
really well done as you can see.
all about professionalism here
But every other map I could find had such tiny little
letters. There's no way you could see it from there. So this is what we got,
but it illustrates exactly what I just talked about that
this once unified Kingdom split into two and
so you see on the North kingdom is the word Israel now
you think but that's Israel from the past, right? That's all
together. Actually. They took the name Israel.
And an allowed as they rejected the authority of Jerusalem and
what God really wanted to do. They became the northern kingdom
and they took the name Israel, and they had the capital
of Samaria.
Now that might be familiar to some of us who know the New Testament
that there was a city that Jesus referred to
regulated visited that Samaria, right and Samaritans. That's
where this all came from this northern kingdom that
broke away said we're we're we don't want your Authority.
Well, the other two tribes that was about 10 of the
tribes did that the other two tribes remained and kept Jerusalem
as their capital and that was the southern Kingdom collectively known
as Judah.
And so you have Israel and Judah and the
Judah line was still going to be David's line. That was where they
the northern King rejected that they didn't want anything to do with David's line
anymore. But Judah kept it as as secure.
By the way, if you want to read all this you can go back and read Samuel Kings and
Chronicles first and second of each of those. It's the whole narrative
right there of all the locations and Kings and the drama like
you think Netflix is good. Go read that
stuff, right? There's a lot there.
But that's where we are now.
So we're at this divided Kingdom once Solomon messed it
all up then then this divided Kingdom happens.
And so then he mentions and Micah 1:1 there's three kings and
all of those kings were in the southern Kingdom the northern
kingdom kind of shot off and did their own thing the southern
kingdoms were Micah was primarily based and these
three kings were Kings in Jerusalem of Judah.
micropside under all three of those
So we need to know who they are, right because this is showing us time and
context who were they first. He says jotham.
Jotham's Dad was Uzziah. Who was the king of
Judah as well?
Now that name Uzi should sound familiar if you were here at the
start where I was reading from Isaiah 6 it was
because Uzziah died that Isaiah saw
this vision of God Uzziah was one of the greatest
Kings in history of Israel of Judah.
and he was a great king for so long had a lot of prosperity and the
kingdom was doing well and then all of a sudden he dies
and
the Nations thrown for a loop. People are like Where's God now?
What are we going to do? How are we going to survive? This man was
our connection in some way.
Well jotham comes to power as the king and he was able to
do. Okay, he kind of held it together enough for a
while. But then what they started to recognize that there was a
threat from the outside coming in.
And there's this nation called Assyria out
to the Northeast.
And they were starting to press closer to
Israel and Judah.
Well jotham dies and a has.
Became the king.
And ahaz took the nation from somewhat
together yet.
far from God
a has trusted political alliances more
than he feared God. He feared people more
than he feared God. He was wicked.
and instead
of helping his Northern Israelite brothers
against that threat from Assyria.
He actually chose instead to partner with
a Syria to protect him and his Nation from
his Israelite brothers in the North.
Instead of these people who came from the same line of Jacob. He
said no, I'm working with the Assyrians and what
that led to is they kind of combined and Israel fell to
Assyria in about 722 BC.
the northern kingdom exiled gone
Just as prophets had predicted by the way.
And so a has is kind of in League with the syrians now
and all the sudden he's thinking well, this is pretty good. They helped me win.
They helped me protected and so he adopts a Syrian
worship.
Even replacing in that Temple the altar
of God with an altar to an unknown God.
As second Corinthians 16 and go read that.
Here's what that's like if we would replace that cross out there with a picture
of Buddha.
you're like
No, that's what happened here. That was the same kind of
idea.
And that idolatry flowed throughout the land even to
the point. So imagine the people of
God just a couple hundred years later got to the
point where child sacrifice was a part of worship.
That's how far you see how far someone who
doesn't fear. God can actually go.
That's what we see a has do.
So Micah's prophesying under jotham, and then
he's prophesying under ahaz. And now there's a third name. His name
is Hezekiah that he prophesies under as the king. That's a
has his son.
And Hezekiah continued on the same practices in
many ways oppression of the poor false worship
all those things.
But here's the difference.
as the Assyrian army started creeping closer
They just taken the North and now they're still like well, let's
just take the South too. So they're creeping down. They're coming towards
Judah. This is about 701 BC as
he's feeling the pressure.
finally
one of Micah's messages got through
to him.
And King Hezekiah all the sudden finally recognizes.
No, we need God.
So he leads a time of repentant prayer in response to that prediction
of Destruction. He says God we need you and he gets on
his face. They get on their faces and God relented. He turned
the Assyrian army away.
And thankfully it led Judah to survive for about another hundred years after
that.
Before they eventually fell to a different Nation called
Babylon.
They had drifted back into many of the
same practices. They'd gone down the same roads. And God said, okay.
Babylon comes destroys
the southern Kingdom and Exiles them
and it was all confirmation of Micah and other prophets
prophecies throughout the whole of those couple
hundred years. They kept saying it's coming it's coming if
you don't repent it's coming.
And God did it.
So when you think about the context that's what we find ourselves in.
That's that's helpful for us to now frame everything else around
as we're seeing Micah say what he says over the
next couple of weeks and months. Like how is he saying is why is
he saying this? Who's he talking to that's what we're saying. I know
things like that are tedious, but you see how important that is.
That we can't just overlay our context onto
Micah and apply it all 100% We have
to understand what they were going through to help us compare and
contrast how we then apply it.
So it's important.
But here's what I want to do with the rest of our time together this morning.
We have the context now.
I want to give you a brief overview of where we're going.
Without giving all of it away like I'm gonna give you
a hint of where we're going, but but I want you to hear.
With that context what Micah will
teach us and what it's going to challenge us with.
And I think there are three main questions that Micah really
implies.
Sometimes explicitly ask there's three main questions that it asks and
answers along the way what's God wanting to get us to
see? What's he wanting to get them to see but also
what you want to get us to see here.
To understand from the book of micahs. We look at God's word.
Here's the first question.
Who is like Yahweh?
We look at this book.
Over the next couple months. We'll look at this book in depth and
what we'll see first is this question asked who is like
Yahweh.
Remember how I started this this message?
the picture of God in Isaiah chapter 6
We actually get a very similar picture in Micah
as I'm going to talk about this next week
a lot more but look at verses 2 through 4 a little preview of Coming
Attractions. It says here you people's all of you everybody listen
up pay attention to Earth all it is
in it and let the Lord God be a witness against you the
Lord from his holy Temple. That sounds
like Isaiah saw God in the temple, right?
For behold the Lord is coming out of his place and it'll
come down and tread upon the high places the Earth. The mountains will
melt before him and The Valleys will split open like
Wax before the fire like water is poured down a steep
place.
Basically, he's saying there is no God like Yahweh.
But here's even the better way that we know this question is asked
in Micah.
It actually goes back to the very meaning of Micah's name.
So, you know names have meanings and and can point us to something
especially biblically. We can see a lot in the names.
But the name Micah.
Means who is like Yahweh.
Like so his very name who is like Yahweh that
question just follows him around his entire life.
Everybody knows when you see Micah that
his the fundamental question of life is who is like
Yahweh.
And as a prophet, he's standing up saying these messages to people and
he's basically asking them by his presence who's like
yelling.
Who is like our God?
In fact, he cleverly ends the book. He starts it
with his own name who is like Yahweh incident seven Eighteen with
the same question. Who's a God Like You
I talked about God's character in that who is who is
like Yahweh. Who is a God Like You So this entire book examines
whether any God or any Idol
can compare can stand against this holy
God.
Can stand against Yahweh can stand against the Lord of all creation.
It's an examination of all of the competitors.
Spoiler alert, there is not one, right?
That's the point of this who is like y'all. It's a
rhetorical question meant to get you to think to say.
No one.
No one who is like Yahweh. There is none worthy
of our worship, but him.
He's holy.
When we say that word, holy we mean he's set apart. He's different.
He's out there different set apart from
us. Holy completely other he's not
tainted not it constrained. He's out
there.
Which means as holy he has every right as the Creator
to Demand right living from those he created and to judge
those who don't live according to that standard.
That's Holiness according to God.
Which leads us into a second question in Micah?
Who is like Yahweh. Well, then who can Ascend to Yahweh.
We see that very clearly who is like Yahweh, but then who can Ascend
to him if if that's who he is. How can
we ever get there?
Because there's this theme this this image of a mountain
throughout God's word that mountain as a place where God
dwells.
It illustrates Holiness, it illustrates separation and power and
sovereignty. That's God's up there. We're down here
and you see it all over.
Like in Mount Sinai when Moses meets with God he
goes up the mountain to meet with God and everybody else. You remember
the story. Everybody else is like scared because they know God's up there
and they're gonna do they're gonna get killed or they're gonna get
run off. They don't know they're scared like Moses you go for us.
We'll stay down here you go up. There you go talk to go because
we don't want to do anything with it.
It was just because
we find it in Jerusalem. Even where on this
mountain that God had met repeatedly with his people.
He commanded his Temple to be built in
that very spot.
So that's where I've met with you over and over again. That's where I'm going to be dwelling in
my place. And the way the scripture talks about is
a word called Zion.
Mount Zion
Throughout God's word. We see that theme show up
and what it points us to is that's God's dwelling place, but it's
also our eventual home.
That we're going to be with God that's going to be where we are with
him. It's also the place that Jesus Will Stand one day
as the king Revelation 14:1, right? So that's that's
all part of this that Mount Zion is like this encompassing location
that says here's where God
is
and it's a mountain.
Micah 4:1 happens to call it the highest of mountains
And says many nations will come to that mountain
that will come to that Yahweh. But
that again reminds us the same question. We're still
asking Psalm 24:3 says who shall Ascend
the hill of the Lord.
Okay, he's on the mountain. That's where he is. He's holy we're scared of that
who's gonna get there?
Who will stand in his holy place?
And Micah doesn't shy away from telling us about the darkness
of judgment for those that are not.
in God's presence
He consistently repeats the darkness of judgment that there
is a God out there. That is a god of judgment, but we
we're down here.
Israel and Judah turn their backs on God they got judgment
for that.
God expected them to be as representatives to the nation. He
had to correct them when they weren't.
That's what first Peter 4:17 says that judgment begins
at the household of God. He cares about how we live
as his people.
So when they worshiped false gods
when they when they committed Injustice is along the way they didn't
care for immigrants. They spoke evil of one another and so
on and so forth God chose to discipline them
to bring them back but in so doing
he revealed that many of them didn't actually trust him in
the first place.
They were leaning on their family line their lineage the
same we're good.
My dad's Abraham, I'm good.
But they didn't have faith.
Trust
in this Yahweh.
See, that's the consistent drum beat even through.
the darkness
is that we all are due his judgment.
Micah is a heavy book.
It shows God's response to sin. It shows his the
cycles of idolatry and judgment idolatry and
judgment and it's dark.
but at the same time
even in this bad news cycle that we're going
to get over and over.
There's a glimmer of good news here.
Throughout this same book that Micah not only shows the darkness
of judgment. He also shines the light of
Mercy in the same book.
It's not all doom and gloom. It's it's actually hints unglimmers
of Mercy throughout that
we need to see.
That yes, we should walk away with a renewed sense
of Holiness and Justice of God. He's going to judge Sinners on
the earth. We should not ever forget that or move past that too quickly,
but he will also show us that he's
a God who is forgiving compassionate.
merciful
at the same time
see God's Not Like Us.
God can be a god of judgment and mercy at
the same time.
Kind of blows our minds but it's true that he will not go back on his promises
to Abraham and to Moses that he's gonna bring a nation
of faith that he's merciful. He's gracious slow to
anger abounding instead fast, love and faithfulness to his
people. That's who he is as well as a god of
judgment.
All throughout this Book of Micah even through
the darkness of judgment. We
see this one word show up. It's a Hebrew word. It's Hess
said you got to get it in your throat. Right past said you
got to say it that way. It's Mercy.
It's the word for Mercy For Loving kindness for steadfast
love that. This is God's love for
his people.
We see it all here. It's Micah 7 the end of
it. He says who is a God Like You.
We've asked the question who is like Yahweh pardoning iniquity.
God forgives passing over transgression for
the remnant of his inheritance. We'll see who the remnant is. He does
not retain his anger forever. He Delights in steadfast
love. There it is.
He again have compassion on us. He'll tread our iniquities Under
Foot you'll cast all our sins into the depths
of the sea.
You'll show faithfulness to Jacob. Remember Jacob is before the
split Jacob and steadfast love to Abraham as
you've sworn to our fathers from the days of old. This is
who God is
Mike at the end of all of the judgment and Declarations
of Destruction. He looks up and says
God you are a god of Mercy.
It's the same thing that Isaiah saw.
Experienced remember at the beginning of the sermon he he saw
the vision of God and His holy Temple. And what
was he in response? He was broken.
Woe is me. I am broken. I am done. I am
among a people. There's no hope for me.
Is how it continues?
Isaiah 6 verse 6 then one of the seraphim flew to
me having in his hand a burning coal. He had taken with
tongs from The Altar and he touched my mouth remember his
unclean lips is what he was talking about. That's my problem
and he touched his lips.
With the coal and he said this behold this
has touched your lips. Your guilt is taken
away and your sin atoned for
Here's what Isaiah experience. Here's what Micah teaches us.
Here's what we need to remember is that yes.
God is a god of judgment, but he at the
same time will bring Salvation.
Mark it's hard. But he's going to bring Salvation and
he's not going to do it just by some kind of like I'm gonna turn the
other way and look look Beyond it. No, he does
it in a way that goes exactly opposite
of what the people had failed at.
So remember the kings were Wicked and they got them in
trouble and they got them divided and they got them all the way around and yet
Micah in Micah
5.
He says here's how God says here's how I'm going
to save you.
I'm going to send a king to be born in a place
that you don't think kings are born from called Bethlehem.
And I'm going to send a king who's going to be your Shepherd. Who's Gonna Be
Your Leader? Who's going to bring you together as you were
separated?
See, he's going to bring a righteous King from the
line of David because remember David's from Bethlehem.
That's where David's family's from.
The line of Judah the king it's this is gonna fulfill
the promise Micah 5.
I'm gonna bring a righteous King through the line of David to
save you my people.
In contrast to all the fickle Kings the wicked kings
that you once followed. Got you in trouble. I'm gonna bring a king
that's going to be merciful. I'm gonna bring a savior king
that's gonna be right.
Here's the beautiful part of this.
For them back then it was a future hope.
This was 700 years before Jesus came. So all they're doing
is they're looking forward to this Messiah savior to come and they're saying
okay God we believe you.
We hope it comes now, but we believe you it's going to come.
What was future for them is now past present
and future for us.
It's what we see that that in part
Micah prophesied about this Micah 5
Shepherd King in part. We have seen that Jesus is
that King born in Bethlehem who came to carry
the Judgment of that sin on himself on the
cross that he is the one who brings us
up the Holy Mountain.
By his own blood shed for us
in his life death and Resurrection in our place. He brings us to
him his blood covers Us.
That we now have hope because of it.
We sing about hope all already today.
Hope is not just wishful thinking hope is based on
something solid.
Even if we can't see it yet.
They were hoping in the Savior King. We know who
that is, and we hope in him as well.
I love how Ephesians chapter 2 illustrates what
my teacher teaches in his book.
This is the New Testament. This is post Jesus. We know the truth
of it, but listen to how similar the ideas are.
Even in the New Testament of what God has done to save us.
Ephesians chapter 2 you were dead.
In the trespasses and sins in which you once walked
following the course of this world following the
prince of the power of the air the spirit that is now at
work in the sons of Disobedience among whom we all once lived
in the passions of our flesh.
carrying out the desires of the body and the mind or by
Nature children of Wrath
Like the rest of mankind does that not sound like Micah's situation?
Everybody's doing whatever they want. Everything's running away from God
and they're dead because of it.
Verse 4 has the two greatest words and all of scripture.
but God
That's the problem.
But God being rich in.
Mercy
Has said loving-kindness steadfast love
being rich in Mercy because of the
great love with which he loved us. Meaning. That's the start is God's love
not our love for him his love for us that love
that he loved us, even when we were dead in that trespass
made us alive together with Christ
by Grace you have been saved and check
this out and raised us up with him and
seated us with him in the Heavenly places in Christ.
Jesus up the mountain remember, right? That's where
we're at with this so that in the coming ages. He
might show the immeasurable Riches of his grace in kindness
toward us in Christ Jesus.
You're in my faith in the mountain. That's right verse
8 by Grace. You've been saved through faith. This is not your
own doing. It's a gift of God not a result of
works. So that no one may boast. You can't climb that mountain yourself.
But God by his grace.
Even in your dead spiritual State.
He said come on.
And he made you alive together any made you whole he
made you present with him together. Praise
God, right?
I mean like in his love what he's done great love
that he's loved us.
In a moment, we're going to sing one of my favorite songs in the world. It's called Living Hope by
Phil Wickham.
And I want you to just listen to the lyrics to this.
It beautifully portrays what we're talking about here is what
it says how it starts how great the chasm that
lay between us.
How high the mountain I could not climb?
in desperation
I turned to heaven and spoke your
name into the night.
Then through the darkness.
Your loving kindness that's that has said
that Mercy right tore through the shadows of
my soul the darkness. The work is finished. The
end is written Jesus Christ my Living Hope
Who could imagine so great a mercy?
What heart could fathom such boundless Grace the
god of Ages stepped down from
glory to where my sin and bear my
shame.
The cross has spoken. I am forgiven. The
King of Kings calls me his own.
Beautiful savior. I'm yours forever.
Jesus Christ my Living Hope.
Man, I'm gonna sing that song differently now, right?
Triumphing over judgment. That's what Jesus did
we see glimmers of it in Micah. We see
it in full in Jesus Christ.
And that Mercy is what then leads us.
It gives us every reason to turn away from sin turn
away from Idols turn away from sin that
brings judgment on us and turn to Jesus
in his work in our place.
Unbeliever, why are you waiting to do that? You see it, right? You
see that judgment is coming for you turn to Jesus today. That's
the only way
But believer listen, this is also for you.
Why do you wait for God's discipline?
Before you go ahead and do what you know, you ought to do already.
Before you give that habit up or before you love that neighbor.
Why wait for God's discipline? Why don't you just go ahead and do it now?
Avoid the pain, you know the right thing to do
do it.
because of his Mercy
See, that's actually the third question here.
Because we know that there's no God like Yahweh.
And we know that it's only by his grace that we're invited up
the mountain to begin with.
The third implied question here. Is that will we live for Yahweh
then?
Micah will ask that question.
How are we living for him?
for God
that's part of the deal here. That's part of the kingdom of God.
We're Representatives. We're ambassadors. In fact, that's what Micah does
so well in Micah 6 verse 8, that's a familiar verse to
so many people. He says this is how you're supposed to live.
God's commanded this he's required this of you. This is
what it says. He's told you. Oh man. What is good? What
does the Lord require of you
talking to his Covenant people the people supposed to be
as Representatives the ones who are supposed to live like him. He says,
what is the Lord require of you?
but to do justice
and to love kindness
has said
and to walk humbly with your God.
Boils it down. I don't know about you, but I like simplicity.
That's pretty simple.
It's not easy.
But it's pretty simple.
That if she always has saved you through Jesus Christ
if that's where you say Jesus is my Lord
and Savior if that's you then your gratitude for
that salvation should lead you to a whole
new life.
Toward a pursuit of Holiness to be holy like
God is separated to not be caught up in all
the junk and the world and the way things are here. Like we
saw in Ephesians 2 we see in Micah don't be caught up in all that.
I'm holy. I'm set apart. I'm distinct.
like God is
Not for my glory, but for his glory if he saved me
then that gratitude should lead to that where I
am doing, right according to God's standard where I
am. I'm loving others with that has said
Mercy that God's love me with
And I'm walking humbly with my God.
That's including like Isaiah responded to this forgiveness.
He says.
Wherever you send me God I'm in.
Includes going on Mission includes what Ephesians 2:10 says
that there's good works God prepared in advance for you to do there's actions
you need to take there's things he's assigned for
you like we talked about last week There's assignments for you.
And you say to him I'm walking humbly with you God that means in on your
mission wherever you're taking me. I'm going
this
this is who he is who is like Yahweh.
No one.
Who can Ascend to him on his Holy
Hill?
Only those who are invited in and cleansed by
him.
But will we then live for him?
only by his grace
And only as we trust in his power to
live it out through us.
This Is Our God